أطلق صواريخه وأزعج جيرانه،
نعم! لقد قض مضاجعهم بترسانته النووية
وصواريخه المدمرة أيضا،
ورائحة القلق تنتشر في الأرجاء!!.
تعيش الدول المحيطة بكوريا الشمالية
توترات غير مسبوقة وهم يستنجدون بأمريكا،
لكنها  لم تنقذ أوكرانيا وهي الحليف الأقرب لها
فهل تنقذ اليابان وكوريا من فم المجنون؟..
في انتظار مخيف وحذر من دول العالم
لرد الدول المتضررة،
هنا يأتي رد عسكري غير متوقع
من كوريا الجنوبية،
وزعيم كوريا الشمالية يكشر عن أنيابه!!،
فهل يكتفي المجنون بهذا القدر من التجارب؟...
محاولات متكررة لاغتيال الرئيس الأوكراني،
و١٠٠ألف جندي أمريكي في أوروبا
فما الذي يفعلونه يا ترى؟
أمريكا تهدد مرة أخرى
وتعمل على تجميع الحلفاء.
تركيا تفتح ذراعيها للشركات العالمية
الهاربة من العقوبات في روسيا،
وبوتين يتحدث عن عنصرية الغرب
وانفتاح روسيا الثقافي على العالم،
زيلنسكي يستعطف المسلمين،
والغاز السام ينتشر في شوارع اوكرانيا
(كوريا الجنوبية تنتقم من المجنون)
أعلنت كوريا الجنوبية  إطلاق عدة صواريخ
برا وجوا وبحرا  إلى بحر اليابان،
( يا لهذا الانتقام!!، وهل أخذوا انتقامهم
من ماء البحر وسمكه عوضا عن الانتقام
من المجنون!!))،
وكان ذلك ردا على إطلاق جارتها الشمالية،
صاروخا بالستيا عابرا للقارات في سواحل اليابان...
هيئة الأركان الكورية الجنوبية أكدت:
أن اطلاق بيونغ يانغ للصاروخ البالستي
يعد خرقا لتعليق إطلاق الصواريخ الباليستية
العابرة للقارات، بينما اعتبرت اليابان
إطلاق الصاروخ أنه يعد تهديدا لأمن وسلامة العالم..
وأكدت أنه أمر لا يمكن القبول به،،
بينما قالت الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
أن إطلاق الصاروخ يعد تهديدا
لزعزعة الأمن في المنطقة،
وبعد هذا كله خرج مجنون كوريا الشمالية
كيم جونغ ليرد على هذه التصريحات
ويشدد على أهمية الصواريخ العابرة للقارات
مؤكدا أنها مفتاح ردع لأي حرب نووية،!!
يكاد المجنون يصيب أمريكا وحلفاءها بالجنون!!
تطورات عسكرية قادمة لا نعلم ما هي حساباتها،
قد يدخلها المجنون ضد جيرانه الذين يحاولون
الانتقام منه بعد تجاربه،
فهل يتم استفزاز كيم ويعلن بنفسه حربا نووية كبيرة؟
(أرقام مهولة)
متحدث عسكري روسي يقول أن أوكرانيا
فقدت ١٤ألف قتيل خلال شهر من الحرب
ويضاف إليهم١٦ألف جريح،
مقابل ١٣٥١ قتيل روسي،،
وأضاف المتحدث أن الحرب كانت لتحرير دونباس
بينما لم يكن في خططهم الهجوم على بقية المدن
لتقليل الدمار والحفاظ على سلامة وأرواح المدنيين،
وهناك ٥ مدن محاصرة بانتظار اجتياحها،،
وقال المتحدث أن القوة الجوية الأوكرانية
تم تدميرها بالكامل تقريبا وتم تدمير منظومات
دفاع الجو وتحييد سلاح البحرية
(وساطة تركية)
أردوغان: يمكن لروسيا وأوكرانيا
التوصل لتسوية بشأن ٤ من ٦ قضايا
تمت مناقشتها،
وأضاف أنه لا يمكنه عمل شيء
بالنسبة للعقوبات على روسيا
بسبب احتياجات تركيا من الطاقة
كما أكد أردوغان أنه يرحب بالشركات الأمريكية
والعالمية المغادرة من روسيا
فأبواب تركيا مفتوحة دائما لهذه الشركات،
فيا لمكرك الاقتصادي يا أردوغان!!!
(روسيا تذم عنصرية الغرب)
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يقول:
إن الغرب يحاول طمس الهوية الثقافية لبلاده،
لافتاً إلى أن الثقافة الروسية ساهمت في تطوير
الحضارة العالمية ولا يمكن إنكارها
وأضاف بوتين “البعض يحاول تشويه التاريخ
الروسي لا سيّما في الدول الغربية”.
ونحن نحمي الثقافة العالمية بفضل ثقافة
العرق الروسي، ولا نتحمل العصبية العرقية،
ونفتخر بأننا نضم عدة مكونات عرقية في روسيا”.
(الأحداث والتطورات)
اسقاط ٤ طائرات بدون طيار باستخدام
نظام الدفاع S1(بانتسير)، الروسي
١٠٠ألف جندي أمريكي في أوروبا
لحماية دول الناتو تزامنا مع حرب روسيا
ضد أوكرانيا،،
كييف تنفي سيطرة روسيا على مدن أوكرانية
كبيرة، وروسيا تعلن تحقيق أهداف المرحلة
الأولى للعملية العسكرية،،
بتحجيم القدرات العسكرية لكييف،
والسيطرة على 93% من أراضي منطقة لوغانسك
شرقي أوكرانيا و54% من مقاطعة دونيتسك..
الأركان الأوكرانية تعلن إسقاط ٣ مقاتلات و٣ مسيرات
ومروحية واحدة و٥ صواريخ كروز روسية
خلال الساعات الماضية
رئيس الوفد المفاوض الروسي:
الطرف الأوكراني يشاور ٣ أطراف
وإمكانيته في اتخاذ القرار محدودة
وروسيا تبحث اتفاقا شاملا مع أوكرانيا
لتلبية مطالبها الأساسية
أوكرانيا تتهم مجموعة فاجنر الروسية
بمحاولة اغتيال الرئيس الأوكراني
فولوديمير زيلينسكي..
أمريكا مع الاتحاد الأوروبي ومجموعة
السبع أقروا عقوبات جديدة على سياسيين
وممولين مقربين من السلطة وقطاع تصنيع
الأسلحة في روسيا..
بينما اعتبرت موسكو قرارات الناتو
رغبة في استمرار النزاع،
أما رئيس أوكرانيا فاعتبر أن تسليح الناتو
لبلاده يعني رد الغزو الروسي
أوكرانيا تحذر من جزيئات غاز دقيقة تنتشر
في سماء كييف وتدعوا المواطنين إلى عدم
فتح النوافذ والمكوث في المنازل
على الأقل لمدة ٢٤ ساعة قادمة
بايدن اتفق مع الاتحاد الأوروبي على خطة
لخفض اعتماد دول الاتحاد على الغاز الروسي
، وخطط أخرى في حال استخدام بوتين
للأسلحة الكيميائية أو في حال تعدت الحرب
حدود أوكرانيا إلى دولة في حلف الناتو،،
قالت وزارة الدفاع الأوكرانية، إن القوات الروسية
تمكنت جزئياً من إنشاء ممر بري إلى شبه جزيرة
القرم من منطقة دونيتسك الأوكرانية.
تدور معارك ضارية في مدينة ماريوبل الأوكرانية،
حيث تحاول القوات الروسية السيطرة عليها،
من أجل ربط شبه جزيرة القرم بشكل كامل
مع الانفصاليين شرق أوكرانيا.
بينما طلبت كييف من الاتحاد الأوروبي،
إغلاق حدوده مع روسيا وبيلاروسيا،
حليفة موسكو في الغزو الذي يشنّه الجيش الروسي
على أوكرانيا منذ شهر.
صور لوصول بايدن إلى الحدود البولندية
الأوكرانية مع تحية للجنود الذين يقومون بحماية الحدود.
القوات الروسية تسيطر على قرية موتيجين غربي كييف
زيلينسكي يدعو لضخ مصادر الطاقة في الأسواق
للحد من هيمنة روسيا ..
وأضاف زيلينسكي: "الغزو الروسي يؤدي لحرمان
دول العالم من الغذاء، كما يجب مواصلة
الضغط على روسيا بالعقوبات حتى نضمن
عدم تدميرها العالم".
وبعد استعطاف اليهود ظهر زيلينسكي
ليستعطف المسلمين بقوله أن "4 آلاف مسلم
يعيشون في ماريوبول التي تقصفها القوات الروسية بشكل عنيف".
ماكرون: قرار روسيا تسعير الطاقة بالروبل
سيدفعنا لإعادة النظر في الكثير من العقود،،
والعقوبات ستستمر على موسكو حتى إيقاف الحرب
صور لاستهداف جوي روسي لمواقع أوكرانية
الغرب أصبح تائها بين متابعة أحداث أوكرانيا
أو الرد على ما يفعله مجنون كوريا،
كل ذلك في ظل ترقب وخوف من التنين الصيني،،
فهل يجعلون كييف تقبل بشروط روسيا؟